[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de cultura de
france 24 un casting internacional en
decorados muy detallados estos son los
ingredientes de la sofisticada película
de friends dispatch después de los niños
exploradores de una vez kingdom y de los
empleadores de su candidata es tutela el
franco filo director estadounidense
weston de acción cuenta aquí la historia
o más bien las historias de los mejores
periodistas de eeuu reunidos en los años
60 en un pueblo imaginario de francia y
la película da vida a los artículos de
estos héroes con caras bastante
conocidas son dos horas de relatos que
se hojean al igual que las páginas de un
periódico
acompañado por la voz de francisco que
el exhibidor del grupo port que
reinterpreta especialmente para los
franquistas unos clásicos de la música
francesa en francés
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en brasil en 2018 las imágenes del museo
nacional de río de janeiro consumido por
el fuego también parecían sacadas de una
película el espectacular incendio redujo
a cenizas alrededor del
85% de los 20 millones de piezas del
principal museo de historia natural de
américa latina' pero este 12 de
noviembre dos años después de la
catástrofe el director de la institución
anunció el inicio de la reconstrucción
cuando el mismo día pero del otro lado
del océano la unesco es decir la
organización de las naciones unidas para
educación la ciencia y la cultura
celebró su
75º aniversario hay mucho simbolismo en
este paralelo porque esta institución es
conocida particularmente por preservar
el patrimonio de la humanidad con más de
1000 sitios culturales y naturales
protegidos en 167 países y en valía la
pena iluminar la torre eiffel
seguimos en parís con un reportaje de
nuestros colegas del canal de france 24
en francés con neuroimágenes legal nos
ofrecen descubrir la ciudad
internacional de las artes un espacio
único que desde 1965 sirve de
microcosmos de creatividad para artistas
del mundo entero
bienvenidos a los pasillos de la cia la
ciudad internacional de las artes en
parís aquí los empleados son agentes
extranjeros imprevisibles creativos y a
veces melancólicos también se les llama
artistas y desde su creación en 1965 más
de 35 mil almas han encontrado refugio
aquí mientras paul indran ensaya sus
escalas unos minutos antes de su
concierto una artista coreana no se
ofrece un interludio de espiritualidad
con su instalación llamada house unos
pisos más arriba la artista iraní samira
solo tiene un deseo trabajar en la
figura del halcón al mismo tiempo
cazador excepcional y presa de los
hombres
más bien quiero hablar de este cuerpo
que representa la violencia por
excelencia con su forma de cazar pero
que también es explotado y violado
porque la domesticación de los halcones
también es muy violento a través del
animal casado puedo hablar de otros
cuerpos explotados tener varias puertas
de lectura y a veces desviar la censura
situados en el mago de parís y en
montmartre estos lugares de vida
permiten dialogar según la leyenda del
vogueing en francia las e indrani allá
haremos nuevos amigos sencillamente esa
es también la magia de un lugar así cost
con su visión tener muchas
nacionalidades diferentes muchas formas
de hacer las cosas venza su fe o una
noche a la semana las puertas de la
ciudad se abren al público un espacio
que inspira también a este arquitecto
alemán el museo que existió la sífilis
de lumen ahora estoy haciendo un
proyecto sobre la propia ciudad me
gustaría pensar en cómo mejorar la
situación social aquí si yo sigo y cómo
mejorar la conectividad entre parís y la
ciudad y la acción así que hice un tema
sobre la propia ciudad financiación
fusil se legitime para este pueblo
artístico no hay más religión que la de
adorar apollon dios de las artes
deseamos esos artistas de la ciudad
internacional de las artes que tengan
éxito en llegar a tanta gente como
taylor swift hace 15 años que la
cantautora estadounidense triunfa sobre
todo con baladas / pop folk y country y
textos muy personales ahora la reedición
de su álbum red ha vuelto a batir
récords 30 temas que la llevaron a ser
número uno de la plataforma spotify en
sólo unas horas una estrategia de reo
gestación para recuperar el control de
sus primeras obras cuyos derechos acaban
de cambiar de manos una vez más hace
felices a sus fans que descubrieron una
versión de 10 minutos de su hit orihuela
adornada con un videoclip que es el
primer cortometraje dirigido por taylor
swift
[Música]
con otra cantautora la argentina
canadienses aún nos despedimos les dejo
disfrutar de su nueva canción de mon
destacada por el fabuloso trabajo del
coreógrafo se adecuadas muchas gracias y
cuídense
y no deje medios como el hudson y muchos
prefieren
[Música]
no
ya mí nos sentimos todos
sigo riendo
para de manito a camatte
sufriste a los coches en esta sala